[Musique]
donc de travail consacrée aux
discriminations dont sont l'objet les
personnes noires ou métisses quelque
chose me dit on les femmes noires ou
métisses quelque chose me dit que 95 99
% des participants
spontanément à cet atelier seront les
personnes dont il est question dans la
matinée renaud muselier par exemple sur
twitter dénonce une phrase raciste voilà
ce qu'il dit en république n'ont aucune
bonne raison au monde ne donne le droit
de faire taire une personne pour sa
couleur de peau si il se trouve que
vient à cet atelier une femme blanche un
homme blanc et c'est assez rare mais
j'aurais tendance à lui dit à l'ats dire
qu' il n'est pas question de le ou la
jeter dehors
en revanche on peut lui demander de se
taire vous êtes en train de dire aux
millions de gens qui nous regardent dont
des femmes dont des noirs dont des gens
qui sont originaires du maghreb qu'ils
sont comparables à l'alcoolisme qui ont
une maladie dans mais ça va pas dire si
le parti socialiste a encore quelques
principes et notamment s'il récuse
comment le récuse cette notion de race
madame pulvar ne devrait plus août
demain être la candidate du parti
socialiste aux régionales
toutes les semaines dans ce pays des
étudiants qui font la queue pour avoir
quelque chose à manger on en parle vous
n'en parlez pas parce pardon pardon on
n'a pas consacré monsieur on n'a pas
consacré il y a quelques jours qui
n'existent lardons monsieur bompard voix
près n'importe quoi ici moi servi dans
la matinale week-end de ses news
j'ai consacré des reportages aux
étudiants en était fini des étudiants
chez eux avec c'est madame pulvar i hier
et demain ce sera quoi
j'en ai assez aujourd'hui que l'on
remette en cause en permanence et je
leur dis ça suffit
la france n'est pas un pays raciste la
france n'est pas un pays d'injustice
fils a dit l'autre jour à la sortie du
sommet de l'union européenne qu'il
n'avait aucun mea culpa à faire aucun
remords aucun constat d'échec
les bras m'en tombent c'est incroyable
quand même de d'être à ce point aveugle
sur soi même je veux dire moi je dis pas
tu en es je dis pas que c'est facile je
pas que j'aimerais être à sa place
honnêtement je sais très compliqué mais
il ya une espèce d'arrogance de
suffisance qui est insupportable
considère qu' il a fait tout bien
d'ailleurs quand quelque chose se passe
bien c'est lui et quand quelque chose se
passe mal c'est de la faute des français
ça fait un an que ça se déroule de cette
manière là ce combat idéologique on doit
le mener pied à pied ses l'islamo
gauchisme qui est derrière ça c'est
justement toutes celles et ceux qui
luttent contre la france et qui veulent
nous faire changer de modèle faux nom du
fait que les les races sont un concept
scientifique qui n'existent pas en
réalité ils dénient l'oral ils dénient
le racisme et ils dénient aux personnes
qui sont victimes du racisme lui droit à
un moment donné de s'organiser de parler
entre eux de discuter entre eux
le vrai sujet c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya
des femmes et des hommes qui sont
victimes de racisme qui sont victimes de
stigmatisation qui sont victimes de
roger c'est ce combat là que nous devons
mener et je trouve qu'on n'en parle pas
assez et que on parle beaucoup des
propos d'être plus le var ou de la
présente de l'unaf j'ai contribué aussi
à cela mais non le combat essentiel
c'est celui contre le racisme il existe
dans notre pays tous les jours sans
doute il faut continuer à prendre des
mesures extrêmement sec tu voudras ce
que proposera le comité scientifique le
1er avril un rapport et nous allons
constater les choses au conseil de
décence de mercredi ce que je voudrais
également c'est qu'on arrête avec la
communication politique et qu'il n'y ait
pas de décalage entre les paroles et les
actes
les autorités égyptiennes tentent par
tous les moyens de dégager le super
cargo bloqués dans le canal de suez
un travail long et difficile pour faire
bouger ce mastodonte de 220 mille tonnes
et 400 m de long ces monstres d'acier
deux fois plus haut que les bâtiments de
venise pourrait bien ne jamais y
retourner
le gouvernement vient de prendre une
décision radicale
interdiction pour eux d'accéder au
centre historique